good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone's having a wonderful splendid
and just
awesome day a wonderful splendid tuesday
tuesdays are an interesting day very
non-descript
but not threatening no you know i was
actually thinking on the way here um
while i was walking i was just thinking
about like you know the different days
and what they signify and like what they
mean to me
and i feel like monday gets like so much
[ __ ] for being the bodiest woe but like
tuesday's
really close to being like [ __ ]
terrible no and it's like technically
tuesday is worse than wednesday yet
wednesdays are like a horrible day
because it's the hump oh really i think
you're the middle of the week you're
just like so
in it i don't think of wednesdays as a
horrible day i think of wednesday
thursday friday is like the ideal days
of the week
monday is the worst and then like
tuesday skates by like not getting its
reputation like shot on even though
i think we should talk about it yeah i
do think we should talk about tuesday
it's just like a silent killer
yeah it's the worst like because it's
not as
obviously bad as monday but it has very
monday vibes
it's an sbd silent but deadly yes
some of theo's favorite activities but i
really don't mind a tuesday i really
don't because it's like okay we're
enmeshed in the week i can do this
like it's already begun the hardest part
of the week is getting started the
hardest part of anything is just
starting
that's true that's very very true so
it's a tuesday
and tuesday it always just like feels
like it should be thursday they're so
similar
same letters it's so true like tuesdays
really feel like
why is it not thursday today yeah like
it could be if we wanted it to be no it
might as well be it might as well be
yesterday was a long day because
it was a long enjoyable day but i spent
my day watching the crown as i said i
would
jackie and i both strategically watched
half we
we caught up to the same amount which i
think is great because we're going to
recap the first half
at the end of the show and then we'll
recap the whole thing once we finished
later this week and i just we've never
done it like that before
but i i have things to say no me too and
i'll forget them when like whatever big
pen ultimate episode happens right i'm
just like enjoying it so much and i was
like
trying to talk to ben it's like talking
to the crown
talking about the crowd to someone who
doesn't watch the crown is like
it's just irrelevant it just falls on
deaf ears and he just like listens to me
but he doesn't
hear me i understand and i'm like ben
the balance of the monarchy
no no kind of the future of the monarchy
is weighing in the balance
kind of like margaret thatcher like she
listens but she she hears but she
doesn't listen to her daughter
to and her her husband on the plane yeah
yeah but she actually did here
yeah um so yes we will dive into that in
the tv recap segment tonight is the
bachelorette which we will be recapping
tomorrow because we are geisha fertaisha
yeah very exciting but other than that
there's no tv on tonight besides the
bachelorette right i mean that's a lot
of tv
it's so much but like literally we
watched six hours of tv last wednesday
so i'm just so now
what's two hours really no we've really
been humbled
yeah uh yesterday i had a busy day with
bruno was his first time watching the
crown and so far his thoughts he thinks
it's impeccably done
is he team diana oh you know what he
definitely has a soft spot for diana
right now as do i
me too i look forward to seeing how
things unfold but like
we'll get into it i have a soft spot for
her right now me too i'm gonna
do a total 360 no 180 from
what i said yesterday um because i've
only seen the first half i hear what
you're saying initially we'll get into
it we'll just
save it and then if you haven't watched
yet you'll definitely catch up
and he obviously loved all the animals
on the hunting
the hunting there the stags there's pups
there's horses
he loves horses he's a lover of horses
i'll have to take him to the stables one
day
one day yeah um that's fabulous so we
will be doing that in the tv recap
segment we have a
delicious fast five stories very robust
very robust stories i actually have some
that i'm very excited to talk about
obviously we'll talk about taylor swift
but i have one story that um i know the
redheads
are going to be interested and i think
that you will too well i'm an author why
wouldn't i be
a little book news pre-order my book
girl with no job.com
book also something we did not speak
about because it's not really pop
culture news but i just think it's worth
mentioning the fact that there's like
two possible cobia vaccines
on the horizon and i just think that
news should be celebrated and now i'm
seeing memes about like
pfizer versus madonna madeira and like
the content is so funny and i'm just
i'm so glad like it's even being spoken
about you know what this is so
i like i'm so excited for a vaccine like
can't wait sign me up
but this goes back to what we're always
saying or one of my general theses is
that like
what like when it rains it pours like
for so long we we didn't have a vaccine
and now and now we have two like
just like you know things that come in
doubles like when
i have the list on my phone and there
were two snow white movies
exactly like that yeah no i know i mean
when her when hurricane harvey and
harvey weinstein were both going down at
the same time like
coincidences it was a month of harvey's
like you keep a note on your phone of
like weird double coincidences yes i do
and this is one of them and snow white
is also one of them no that one was
weird like snow white and the huntsman
and then like snow
where mirror yeah that was bizarre and
like they literally were in theaters at
the same time
it's like space them out we never get
snow white movies like why two in one
month i know and like you would be at
the movie theater walking down the
hallway and like
it was literally theater two snow white
and the huntsman theater three like the
other one like yeah it was so bizarre
i feel like that happens a lot like i
feel like even um
the jobs movies yes the steve jobs
movies
or i feel like we've just got like two
ted bundy things we also got like
six diana documentaries like all in the
same month yes
we're gonna have a few years ago kristen
stewart one also coming out yes
um that is so true i just feel like
every time there's like a
person of interest like a group of
celebrities get together and we're gonna
and
are like this is gonna be like the
record like we want this to be like the
one and then like a bunch of celebrities
a few years later like do the exact same
thing and then neither of them are
right but the crown to me like is a
really really or the closest we're ever
going to get to an accurate retelling of
history i completely agree like so i
believe them when they say
and whatever they say about like diana
like i will believe the crown yeah but
watching this season is interesting so i
feel like all the other seasons
we watched through the lens of the queen
but this season it really felt like in
the beginning with margaret thatcher
like we were watching the queen through
margaret thatcher's lunch and i was like
queenie you're not being nice
no i was also thinking that queenie was
um
was like kind of fading into the
background especially with the diana
stuff
yeah we were yeah we'll talk about it
but it is like i'm not looking at diana
through the queen's eyes i'm looking at
the queen through diana's eyes yes
and the queen's kind of [ __ ] yeah and
like all they're like the most miserable
family and all of a sudden margaret
thatcher comes in the house is jumping
oh and they were so rude to her they
were so rude they're like they're having
so much fun they never have fun
we need to we need to preserve this
conversation for our tv recap
so let's just get let's just get on with
it let's get on with it
into the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
no oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god i
got it do you need the first aid kit
oh yes give me my rdh medicine i think
it's in your hands
today's episode
today's episode is brought to you by
frame brit frame bridge frame bridge
makes it easier and more affordable than
ever to frame your favorite things
without ever leaving the house excuse me
there is a fuzz on my eye
from art prints and posters to the
photos sitting by your phone you can
frame bridge just about anything
it's the perfect way to give easy and
thoughtful gifts in just minutes you can
turn a photo from your phone
into one of your best gifts ever
framebridge is like a company that's
like living in another century like it's
just the way that they do everything is
like so easy so fast
and the fact like honestly the framing
industry is so archaic like
the fact that it takes like weeks for
your frame to get done and literally
costs an arm and a leg the fact that you
can just upload from your phone to this
website framerange.com
and choose a frame and then it just like
shows up at your house like that's
they're living in the year 3000 they're
living in the future and that movie back
to the future instead of flying cars
they should have it's a website where
you can get something framed no it's so
true you just go to framebridge.com
upload your photo or they'll send you
packaging to safely mail in of a
physical photo
um you can preview your item online and
dozens of their frame styles gallery
wall layouts
choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers
the experts at frame bridge will custom
frame your item and deliver your
finished piece straight to you
to you or anyone on your list a
handcrafted personalized gift from frame
bridge starts at 39
and all shipping is free plus our
listeners will get 15
off their first order at framebridge.com
when they use the code toast
so get started today frame your photos
or send someone the perfect gift
go to framebridge.com and use promo code
toast to save an additional 15
off your first order go to
framebridge.com promo code toast
framebridge.com promo code toast olivia
was just saying that she has like a
million pictures of michaela on her
phone and none frames and i'm like
olivia
go to framebridge.com code toast and she
did yeah i'm gonna need to
get some framed of bruno i'm gonna need
to get some more michaela photos in my
house i don't have enough
yeah it's it's photo time it's funny
sign on get your frames
first story really the big story of the
day taylor swift is speaking out after
scooter braun
let me take that scooter try that again
scooter taylor swift is speaking out
after scooter braun sells her masters
for 300 million dollars
taylor swift's masters have exchanged
hands yet again
and the grammy winner is speaking out
about the most recent sale scooter braun
who obtained control of swift's masters
when his company ithaca holdings
acquired big machine league
label group in june 2019 from founder
scott borchetta
sold the master rights of her first six
albums for more than 300 million dollars
variety reported on monday
shortly after the news broke taylor
shared a statement on twitter
explaining that she had attempted over
the past year to enter into negotiations
with braun to buy her work back
but would have been required to sign an
iron-clad nda
stating she would only speak positively
about the entrepreneur before being
allowed to look at big machines
financial records
quote so i would have had to sign a
document that would silence me forever
before i could even have a chance to bid
on my own work swift said
something she added her legal team said
was absolutely not normal
she said that scooter never would never
even quote my team of price these master
recordings were not for sale
to me they um sold them to shamrock
holdings who reached out to taylor last
month following the sale
with hopes of working together right but
taylor said in the letter back that she
quotes simply cannot in good conscience
bring myself to be involved in
benefiting
schooner broadens interests directly or
indirectly because
she then learned that he'll still make
money even
holds them the scooter will still make
money right so
there's so many things going on here one
you and i were saying like we were a
little confused if
scooter sold all of big machine or just
taylor's masters
to shamrock it's sounding like it's just
the master it's sounding like it's just
the masters but i swear the article that
i read yesterday and i read it from
e because i clicked the link in their
bio from their instagram it said that he
sold big machine and i was like that
affects rascal flatts too so like
and i was like well this is misleading
right he's not just getting rid of
taylor's work or
deciding what happens to her history but
now and i read like three different
stories this morning and the original
variety article cause i'm like well
which one is it
right and i'm going that it is just a
master's yeah yeah now to me the most
interesting thing here is that however
much
scooter braun originally paid for them
they are worth
much less now because taylor has vowed
to
never sing them like she will not make
unless she owns her masters like she
doesn't want to make anyone any money so
i'm really surprised that he could
manage to sell it for so much
and like make a profit when they're
really worth less than they were when he
bought them
but maybe shamrock thought that they
would be able to work with taylor and
then when taylor found out that scooter
was still involved like
honestly i don't think this is a good
investment for shamrock like she's she
in her statement she has said she's
already started re-recording her music
which she's now legally allowed to do
starting november 22 it's been a great
process for her creatively
and there's lots of little surprises
sunglass emoji smiley face
so like i actually think just like from
a financial standpoint like i don't know
who would want these
masters now because of course they still
generate revenue but not in like
taylor's fans have
vowed to not stream them to not buy them
taylor will never perform them so like
it's just it's not a good investment at
this point i feel like honestly scooter
braun wanted to
unload them because he still wants to
wash his hands of this whole situation
no i don't think so oh i do i don't
think he wants to be
the man who owns taylor swift's masters
anymore i don't know i mean this is
every time the story comes up it's like
i have no idea how the music industry
works
and even though she's not going to
perform them and her fans aren't going
to buy them
they get to choose what happens to all
these songs they could put them in a
million commercials they can put them in
movies they can sell them
and they're but that does devalue them
when you like [ __ ] them out
uh yeah but there are so many and
they're such great hits like so i think
if they weren't worth that much they
wouldn't have paid this much what i do
think is interesting though is what she
says about the nda
and the fact that she technically did
have the opportunity to buy them back
but not without signing an nda that
pretty much said that she would never
speak about scooter again unless she had
something nice to say well
she had to sign that nda just to even
start talking and get a look at the big
machine financials she wouldn't do
which yeah so it wasn't even she decided
the nda before she could even start
talking about like price so like yeah it
was so far out
um yes but then if you think about it
like
i think it kind of makes sense why they
would ask her to sign an nda because
whatever he
whatever came of the conversation even
if it didn't go anywhere she would say
scooter tried to sell me my
songs for way too much or way too little
like undervaluing them
you know trying to make money off of me
making money off myself like
i just i understand why he was like
let's just
have an nda so neither of us could talk
about it and unless you want to say
something really nice about me
not like forcing you to say nice things
i think well yeah the forcing to say
nice things is really weird but like no
but that's not what he's saying he's
just like you can't speak about me
unless you have something nice to say
no no what she said was that the nda
said like he could only speak about her
in a positive way
right which is another way of saying
like he she just can't speak negative
which i feel like if they had come to a
good agreement and like wanted to like
make the deal happen
then that nda came up like taylor might
have signed it because like she was so
close to getting her life's work like
what's this one nda
but to have put it in front of her like
before she could even like
start the negotiations or start the
conversations like that's
shady but it's just like must be very
difficult for taylor like
now this is like the second opportunity
where she got so close to buying like
her life's work and like had to pass it
up like
because she couldn't in good conscience
do it you know yeah but i also think
that she's made peace with the whole
situation me too
so and she's re-recording them which is
very exciting for us and it's like not
like it's
this is new information and now the
masters even though scooter will still
benefit
they're in the hands of a group that it
seems like she
feels fine towards yeah yeah the letter
that she wrote to them which she
published on her twitter was like nice
and sweet
yeah so it must feel better if they're
in a better place
yes and i just i think it's best for the
world that it's no longer scooter brawn
the taylor swift holding on to her
masters i mean it's better for everyone
like for taylor for scooter for us
yeah for sure for the our relationship
yes it's good
and you know what it's like now all
these
you know rich people are fighting and
we're going to benefit because we're
going to get new taylor new taylor new
old tale
mixes hopefully some tour versions like
we're gonna get we're gonna benefit yeah
maybe shamrock will put the songs in
some movies on some commercials
you know we'll hear it while we're
waiting for housewives to come back like
i think that's exciting
yeah okay next story follow up from last
week's news and i'm just i'm not pleased
to be reporting this i know once i do i
i don't think we'll speak about it again
but i just want to confirm what we
thought
scott disick has a sexy beach day with
amelia hamlin
scott disick and amelia hamlin have
taken their rumored romance to santa
barbara
santa baby bro no time for jokes right
now because
bikini model because scott disick 37 was
spotted on the beach with his arm
wrapped around the 19 year old daughter
of lisa renna
and harry hamlin who was wearing just a
teeny bikini for the outing
as seen in the photos posted by tmz this
is the rumored couple's third public
outing in as many weeks
and i'm gonna go ahead and stamp a
confirmation in this relationship that
they are
in fact dating and not just
collaborating
yeah no unfortunately unfortunately i
think she's more than just a model for
talentless
um and i don't know why that this
particular um
relationship seems to be bothering
people more than others that have like
similar age gaps like even when he
started
dating sophia like people were weird
about it but there was never this much
like people are taking a really firm
stance here
um even like when i think of other
couples like leonardo dicaprio
and cami marone like they have such a
big age gap
but no one really um thinks of it as
like predatory but like people when i
was just reading social media like
post last night people are very um
unhappy about this i'm one of those
people me too 100 and i don't know why
we're like taking it more seriously than
other ones and i feel like it's because
as what we what we really know about
amelia hamlin is like
her parents like we just think of her so
much as a child yeah we saw her on tv
and it's like she lives at home and her
mom's helping her pay rent like
literally like a 16 year old like
she's from what we know about her it's
like we only know like her most immature
qualities you know
that's a good point but also for me it's
like i know leo is like the biggest star
in the world but i
actually like don't really care about
like i don't stand or fly or anything
but like we know scott
we were just talking about him on the
show like i feel so fondly towards him
like we know him like
you feel connected yeah i do i i'm a fan
of his and it's just disappointing to
see this behavior
like over and over again and and i feel
like with sophia at first everyone was
really
grossed out really really grossed out
he's like she's kylie's friend
and no one was here for it but after a
whole year of dating we we came around
and we were like you know
love doesn't have an age but when
everyone you date
is younger than that person that came
before it's a pattern
it's a pattern and it's and it's not
it's not a good one
yeah i feel like a society has just been
very like on high alert recently
of like the whole hollywood grooming
process which is good because it's like
a really big problem
um and this is just this is definitely a
red flag for me
yeah it's a red flag for me i i have no
ship
in this race not to mention like i just
know lisa arena is like dancing in her
backyard like i'm gonna be a kardashian
and like i just hate that i have no ship
in this regatta no
i'm not going to the gala i'm sitting at
the regatta gala this year yeah
me too i just now that we've let you
know that they are probably most
definitely dating i'm not going to talk
about them again because me too i i
don't feel like um perpetuating
their rising their star yeah i agree
but a rising star a star who is shining
normani says being in fifth harmony took
a toll on her confidence
she says i didn't believe in myself oh
my god the more that like we learn about
fifth harmony
over like the years with ali's memoir
and just like everyone talking about it
like
how toxic was it yes when i thought they
were just like five best friends who got
like plucked in from obscurity and like
are living their dream it's like
literally the premise of the cheetah
girls you know right and it's not that
people magazine has a first look at
normani's appearance on the cover of
women's health
the motivation singer opened up and we
heard people have yeah exclusive
of her on another magazine like yeah
just released the magazine no i know but
like they like to tease us the edit like
the magazine industry like makes no
sense i know they're trying so hard
they're just struggling they're like so
true the exclusive and are exclusive and
like maybe the exclusives
no they're trying so hard like it's
killing them
yeah the motivation singer opened up in
the latest cover for stories
for women's health about her life in
lockdown and how she keeps her high
self-esteem
after being in fifth harmony it altered
quote it alters the perception you have
of yourself she said of being overlooked
in the group originally
comprised of her ally brook camila
cabello diana jane and lauren draghi
it's by the way it's so true because the
when they were on x factor and even
after that like camilla was so clearly
like the star of the band and i think a
lot of people were wondering
why at x factor they put her in a group
and why because she they all auditioned
by themselves and then
they all got cut but then simon thought
it'd be good to throw them together so
they got like a second chance
which ended up making them but like
camilla everyone thought she was so
far superior in terms of talent that
like she should have been a solo artist
and she could have won the whole
competition
and now it's like when we take a look at
what all the girls have done i think
most people would say that normani is
actually the most talented
vocally and dance-wise right so
it's so it's like one to be in a group
where there's
a clear quote-unquote star and you're
being overlooked it's a shitty feeling
and that's
a 15-year-old right and then imagine
also oh no but you're actually also the
most talented one
right so like normani eventually did get
her justice
but to be like at such an impressionable
impressionable
age i can be like scarred like i can
actually imagine
now i could see how like traumatizing it
was i feel like some people were just
like really genuinely happy to be along
for the ride and fifth harmony
alleybrook like because i didn't really
feel like she could keep up with the
other girls but
now she's like in this huge you know
global group
but for people like normani and maybe
even camilla who thought that they were
too good for the group like
they actually were yeah she said having
certain things happen so blatantly while
also feeling like the other and being so
young
and hearing the public comparison took a
toll on my confidence
for a long time i didn't believe in
myself because i didn't feel like i was
given the opportunity to
today she says she does daily positive
affirmations to start her day
to boost her self-esteem like candace
dillard bessette
she says i look at myself in the mirror
and manifest and speak things that i
want to happen
as if they already did as if i'm already
that version of myself
not like candace no i kind of i gotta
start doing that i used to think like
[ __ ] like that was so lame like
leaving post-its on the wall and like
talking to yourself and i actually think
i could really benefit from yeah no i
think like i remember one day i was like
getting ready and
um at when i finished my glam i like
just looked in there and i smiled at
myself
and i was just like and it just it set
me on like a great vibe for the day but
i didn't do it like i need to do it more
well you know when we were at fat camp
we used to take this class called be
your best with bobby and there was that
song about like what you should do every
morning you should
accentuate the positive eliminate the
negative
latch on to the affirmative don't mess
with mr in between
which i don't really understand uh the
lesson there but i just think we need to
like be positive yeah we just need to
like
i need to start like affirming myself
you know yeah i mean you you would do
affirmations like before your shows so
you're actually quite an affirmative
queen i would do affirmations before my
show
um but that was just because i was so
nervous like i just needed something to
do
whereas like i think i should just start
my day out like telling myself like i'm
a bad [ __ ]
yeah try it let us know how it goes yeah
maybe i'll work on some post-its too
i'll let you guys know yeah start with
start with the affirmations and then
like you can build up to the post-its
because those seem like more work
yeah maybe like as i'm brushing my teeth
i'll be like
with the electric toothbrush in my mouth
like you are such a star claudia like no
one has a better toothbrush than you
that's so true no one has a better smile
we talk about bruce here all the time
and today's episode is of course brought
to you by one of our favorite products
here
the bruce b-r-u-u-s-h bruce your teeth
don't brush them
brushing your teeth can be a chore but
brushing is fun and 100 times
as effective bruce cleans your teeth at
31 000 movements a minute where manual
toothbrushes tap out at just 300
many electric toothbrushes are barely a
step up for manual ones
and some of them do a good job but they
can cost over 200
so jackie and i have been brushing now
for three or four months they're so cute
first of all they come in like
millennial pink
that's the color we both have um they
have this fabulous magnetic stand so it
looks very sleek on your on your
countertop
it's really just a fabulous experience
i've been using a manual toothbrush like
my whole life and
i have like not great teeth hygiene and
i definitely feel like a huge difference
in my breath and my teeth like
ever since using an electric toothbrush
ben is obsessed with the two when you
buy it you get a travel set
you get um heads uh swap yeah swappable
heads
so your partner can use it or you don't
have to buy a new one it's really
fabulous and
i think as far as all electric
toothbrushes this is the best one on the
market and it's very reasonably priced
for an electric
toothbrush and if you want to stay 15
off of your brush
when you use the promo code toast at
bruce.com so you can try it 90 days risk
free
and get a two year warranty at bruce.com
but you have to use the promo code toast
again that's b-r-u-s-h dot com promo
code
toast love it sign on bruce away
okay next story some book news
my fellow author of your fellow author
so i'm sure you've heard of the book
where the crawdad sings yes
it is the number one fiction novel of
2020. it has sold like over four million
copies and now it's being turned into a
movie
reese witherspoon is at the house
they're producing it for hello sunshine
with a bunch of other
esteemed producers the big news is they
have their main character
well so before for those who haven't
read it what's the book about okay so
i'll read deadlines recap because it
pretty much
sums it up the story takes place in the
mid 20th century south
and centers on kaya a young woman who
was abandoned by her family
and has to raise herself all alone in
the marshes outside of her small town
the the see the setting is very obx okay
they reminded me of one another and
apparently i wasn't the only one
however when her former boyfriend is
found dead kaia is thrust into the
spotlight
instantly branded by the local
townspeople and law enforcement as the
prime suspect for his murder okay it is
an amazing book if you haven't read it
yet i'm sure like everyone who
everyone has read it um but they've cast
their kaya
okay and it's daisy edgar jones who
played marianne in normal people
you know oh my god i actually i'm sure
you're waiting to be like why do i care
yeah no i'm like who daisy um i actually
loved her in normal people
and she obviously does great work in tv
shows that are being adapted from books
so
i'm really excited for her and that's
great yeah
i don't know who i would have cast in
this role i never thought about it long
enough it wouldn't have been her but now
that it's her like i see it totally
what's her name daisy edgar jones that's
just weird because i feel like the other
most popular book this year was daisy
jones and vi
oh for sure and normal people and now
she just has like a monopoly
on all of us on all of the books well
that's very exciting for um
it's a movie or a tv show it's going to
be a movie like in theaters hopefully
yeah hopefully it should be a really big
movie it's a really good um
book and they have you know the film is
being directed by olivia newman and the
screenplays written by oscar-nominated
scribe
lucy alibar so i've really been missing
going to the movies recently like
no i feel like this is going to be a
movie i guess we'll come out like next
to so in like 2022 oscars watch out
right right but do you think we'll be
able to see it in theaters by then we
have two
possible vaccines yeah i think it's
possible i think it's possible too
so that's just some exciting news very
exciting fifth and final story a little
more exciting news
dan and shay darius rucker and more are
set to perform at the cma country
christmas
oh my god you know they were showing
commercials for this during the cma
awards it's going to be hosted by thomas
and lauren atkins yeah and now we have
some lineup
kelsey ballerini gabby barrett florida
georgia line lady a little big town i'm
sorry claudia
and tim mcgraw-hay snitch are also set
to perform
on the show um okay look really quickly
i want to talk about this but um
did you see like the t that like all the
florida georgia line members like
unfollowed each other there's only two
and
their wives like unfollowed each other i
mean i didn't see it but you like margo
showed it yes yeah yeah i wonder what's
going on
i know i just like i need like i live
for drama but not for them like i love
them they're a great duo like please get
it together
i need to like confirm it for myself and
like go and make sure that i didn't i
did
that's bad both of the so there's two
main singers tyler
and brian actually his name is brian
kelly which is so weird because that's
brian kelly's name
um and they each have wives and
now the all four two couples do not
follow each other on instagram like none
so i don't know what the t is and i'm
like really shook by it and i'm really
upset because like i'm a big fgl fan
and this is like a quarantine breakup i
couldn't deal with no i know
just like just but we have to praise you
guys yeah just try and think like
there's
a reason and it's fine and it's gonna be
okay it's gonna be okay like maybe they
just
had like a misunderstanding yeah maybe
they're phone glitched like
yeah no and like people fight with their
friends all the time but they they get
over it think about how many times the
banner
rules cast and follows each other on
instagram that's very true a little
perspective it's surprising that carrie
underwood isn't performing at the cma
country christmas because she has her
new
christmas album my gift is kelly
clarkson and brad eldridge performing
there oh
speaking of christmas songs they're not
speaking of christmas songs speaking of
christmas songs
why don't you speak of christmas songs
the jonas brothers released a christmas
song which is actually quite beautiful
yeah we were talking about it on
halloween remember yeah oh we were
and they released a music video for it
um which i didn't watch but then
somebody dm they were like you have to
watch the
jonas brothers christmas music video and
i did and it's basically just a montage
of like old videos um from their family
christmases
versus like their new christmases with
their families like the turner's the
chopras like
the uh the danielle's i don't know her
last name
danielle jonas right um and so they
actually use so last
uh last christmas they bought uh
four or five of our toasty lights
sweaters and
wore them all over their christmas and
it was so cute and then they used the
photos from their christmas wearing the
toasty like sweatshirt
from our store our merch store in the
music video so
very exciting very good for business
lots of questions about the toasty light
sweatshirt
if it will be back it is going to be
renewed and revamped and rejuvenated
yeah it's gotten the little ramona
singer sharon geezy facelift
yeah we're really excited about it stay
tuned for halloween merch updates coming
soon yes
but cma country christmas is very
exciting so are they singing
original christmas songs i'm sure there
no i'm sure they're doing covers so yeah
you know all the holiday classics dan
and chay have their own country song
that they
just released oh nice so they'll
probably be singing that i feel like
some country artists
have a christmas album that's just
beautiful are they
performing they are did you end up
watching darius rucker and reba
on andy cohen no i did not
it was really good maybe i'll get to it
but like my content plate has just been
so full i know i really enjoyed it like
i've actually just been thinking about
it a lot
since then because reba was like such an
open book and i feel like andy didn't
know a lot about darius rucker but like
left the interview like with a lot of
respect for him
um and i just really enjoyed it and if
anyone's looking for any sort of content
upper
it was it's kind of like an evergreen
episode they just talked about like
country music in general it wasn't that
like topical
um i think you guys would really enjoy
it i did nice okay i'll have to add it i
need to actually start making a list not
just a mental list of all the things
that i've been meaning to watch because
they just slip through my fingers what
else
i don't know i just feel like i'm always
like no it's on my to-do list well
you're gonna watch the undoing
yes but i like that i'll remember that's
like
you know that's a whole weekend yeah and
also just a little tea
i wanted to discuss but not make a whole
story cause like it's like instagram
drama but are you seeing all this drama
going around about dale cipriani kissing
a girl oh my god i got all these dm's
dale was at cipriani on saturday night
with like two girls and he was drunk and
he was allegedly
and he kissed one and
i don't know i don't like want any part
of that no i didn't want any part of it
like
we um certain drama like i can just
tell when like some i get a lot of dms
i'm like some of it's actually good tea
and then like it ends up being true
but i don't like spoiling it like
sometimes i know it's hard to know but
you got to know where the line is and i
saw this and i'm like [ __ ] i want no
[ __ ] part of this
yeah like they're claire and dale are so
messy and like all
people are just like so suspicious of
them and they're just like on their
instagram pretending everything's okay
like they live in another universe
that is so funny the name clarendale it
sounds like irondale from frozen
clarendon totally that's a good one
um okay now we can finally like do what
we came here to do which is talk about
the crowd
tv recap segment brought to you by noom
getting in shape doesn't have to be
about losing a specific amount of weight
or a magic number on the scale
it's about building healthier habits and
feeling better about yourself if fitting
into a favorite pair of jeans is your
goal
great but there are many reasons why you
might want to practice self-care and
everyone is different
yeah for me like if i'm ever like on a
good track trying to lose weight it's
not like for a number on the scale it's
just like if i feel
good like when i'm when i'm like really
not taking care of myself like i get
headaches i get super tired
so there's a ton of different reasons
why you might want to join new because
noon is the habit-changing solution
that helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food
through personalized courses based in
psychology neum teaches you why you do
the things you do
and empowers you with the tools you need
to break the bad habits and replace them
with better ones
newman's not a diet it's easy and a
healthy stick
it's a easy it's a healthy and easy to
stick to way of life
no food is good bad or off limits on
noom they teach you moderation which is
so lovely and can be used in conjunction
with many pre-existing popular diets
if you want so i know you do know carb
you can do noon with that or you can
just do noom on its own
numa is one of the biggest and most
accurate food databases available that
lets you track meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance
we're all strapped for time so noom is
just asking you to commit 10 minutes a
day for yourself
you're human so if you go off track
there's absolutely no shaming with noom
they just give you tips to help you get
back on track tomorrow chat with your
girl specialist in the new community to
get and give help to people going
through the same things
you know i went to the doctor recently
and she asked me if i used a food
tracker
and um i said i used noom and she said
that's actually the only one she
recommends like
that's what the doctor said i'm not even
i'm not even lying you don't have to
change it all in one day
small steps make big progress sign up
for your trial at noon
n-o-o-m-dot-com toast
what do you have to lose visit noom.com
toast to start your trial today
that's n o o m dot com slash
toast love it i have been using noon for
the last few months just to
like you know manage everything going on
and it's just
it's the best and it also like once you
input all of your information in your
work like
you have their help like it takes your
mind off of it it's not like top of mind
they're doing the work for you
exactly okay let's talk about the crown
so fabulous so exciting i have to say
i was really glad i mean i'm only five
episodes in but i'm glad that like the
whole thing isn't diana because
while it is very interesting my favorite
thing about the crown is kind of what it
teaches you like about history and like
all those random episodes of things
you've never heard about like who knew
that someone broke into buckingham
palace and sat at the queen's bed for 12
minutes
that's what i love so i'm glad that
we're getting the diana t but i'm also
glad we're not shying away from the
randomness like margaret thatcher's son
went missing on like a ride through
algeria oh my god totally or that there
was like a war in the falklands
right yeah no it's like it's actually a
really educational show and so as much
as i live for like the gossip the meghan
markle
that type of stuff i actually really
enjoy like getting to know about
britain's history and like the most
random things that like sound made up
but they're not like the first one which
happened in the first episode so
spoiler um i did not know that lord
batten was assassinated
dead so upset i was in shock and as that
scene was progressing
i was like why is this being filmed so
[ __ ] weird yeah like with all the
hunting and the fishing and the
you know and the men walking and the
underneath the water view i was like
who's directing this episode like i was
like this season is weird and lord
mountbatten was literally my favorite
even though
i do think he is to blame for the entire
princess diana
camilla parker's bowl thing but he
really had good intentions like he was
just trying to help everyone whose idea
was it when they sat around last season
it was granny it was queen mother and
lord man batten like really and the
queen when they were
when they had like camilla and andrew's
parents come and said like your kids
need to get married
yeah like it was really biggest mistake
in history i know and of course like
you know hindsight is 20 20 how were we
ever going to know that like charles
the biggest [ __ ] of all time like if i
could describe prince charles
even though i okay hold on i have so
many thoughts writing through my mind i
need to like literally organize them the
first is
if i could describe prince charles in
one word it would be
weak like he's so weak the other thing
is that
of course i pause every two seconds to
like literally watch the real footage
because they're doing such an amazing
job
and literally it's impossible to
decipher between you know
diana and charles on the crown and diane
and charles like in real life when they
did that interview where he said that
weird thing like oh my god yeah
i wrote it down where they asked what
does that even mean are you guys
in love and he said whatever in love
means so bizarre
um but the actor who plays charles like
is unbelievable his posture and how his
hands are like and he's always weirdly
in his pocket
it's always like with his head down it's
like i thought they make you have books
on your head
yeah just have good posture like why is
he always like everyone needs to have
good posture except for the future kick
yeah he's the worst posture bothers me
so much yeah like maybe he isn't
jen has to sit with has to speak with
her hands tied out in her body but he
gets to
hang his head no totally it's bothers me
so much he bothers me so much
so lord man baton when he got killed i
was actually really sad because i
thought he was like a good person and he
and he really did have good intentions
aside watching the crown you have to
like really just
you have to push out the fact that a lot
of these people were like tied to nazis
because
if you if you can't forget that like you
won't like anyone um
and lord matt batten like and phillip
give me like nazi vibes
but they weren't nazis like it's it no
they grew up like near them
yeah no he's like his sister philip
sisters were nazis but like then they
died very tragically yeah when that
plane went down i was like right but
like
he was he wasn't so yeah what are you
gonna do
it's just like it gives me nazi vibes
and and like i think that the crown has
been like a very
anti-nazi and when they found out that
the abdicated king was like
talking with hitler they were like what
the [ __ ] happened 100 100
no you're right you're right but it's
just it's so close to like that time
period but that's also because it's like
recent history yeah
well also the thing is it's like i feel
like in the beginning of the crown they
were moving
so fast and now i feel like they're
moving very slow yeah well they're
i think this you know time period is
more interesting and they're
sort of savoring all of it but they had
a lot of ground to cover in the
beginning
yeah well i was really sad when matt
batten got um assassinated i loved him
and i didn't know that that's how
his journey would end and he was
philip's uncle yeah okay uncle dicky
yeah
but also like a surrogate dad for for
both of them right um
okay that okay i need to talk about
margaret thatcher's son going missing
which was just like a bit of history i
never knew so bizarre but the scene
where he comes home and he's being a
little [ __ ]
at the table i was like and i was like
margaret thatcher is like this amazing
woman but when it comes to her like
in great sun right she's just like
doting on his hand and foot i was like
someone needs to give this kid like a
dose of a slap in the face he was
so obnoxious like when he was just like
the what do you expect from bedouins
like
so [ __ ] rude and rescued your ass
yeah and he was like well they took him
so many days oh no the [ __ ] you were
like he was bothering me so much and
that's kind of just like a funny i feel
like metaphor it's like margaret
thatcher i feel like
i think is like regarded as one of the
greatest rulers iron lady
yeah there are movies about her like
she's an amazing and like at the end of
the day like even
she's like weak to the powers of her son
like she's just a mother like
it's really funny um but that scene
bothered me a lot too and like only the
the daughter and her husband could see
how insane the sun was being like
oh i knew where we were others were
starting to freak out but i knew bloody
hell where we were
it's like no you didn't [ __ ] i know you
were scared relaxed no 100
that was that was shocking yeah it was
crazy i agree
um also speaking of margaret thatcher so
the scene when she goes to balmoral
and they have like all these tests and i
just feel like in every other season
like the
the family like doesn't know it's so
boring they're so boring they like
they hate being royal because there's
nothing to do nothing to talk about like
and all of a sudden
they're having guests and they're having
so much fun they can't even pay
attention to their guests i'm like where
has this family been all along you guys
seem like a very happy bunch
yeah no i actually like felt so bad for
her when like she didn't have outside
shoes and it was just like
she was just like so awkward i know i'm
glad that she left
yeah of course my god like get out of
there even though that looked like a
fabulous weekend but like i really just
and and now where we ended episode five
like the last scene that we saw was
margaret
thatcher and her um victory parade and
like she's waving like the queen and
so it sets you up for like that guy who
snuck in was like she's coming for your
job
right and so it just like put plants the
seed in her head of like queen versus
queen
you know um but in the beginning in the
first episode i really thought they
would get on a dynamic duo yeah and
maybe they are
i did they come to be one but right now
there's some friction
yeah um let's talk about obviously the
meat and potatoes here which is diana
and camila parker's bowl when they went
to that um
parker bowles thank you i'm i'm [ __ ]
up my plurals yes
parker's bowl nope parker bowles yeah
okay i'm definitely multiple bubbles
yeah parker bowles
um that meal was really awkward like
camila
parker bowles is just so obnoxious like
oh freddie gladys like oh you don't know
he loves a garden oh he doesn't eat
lunch and she gets bloated like
shut the [ __ ] up wait i hate girls
that's like the one upper you know for
sure but also the fact that
he doesn't eat lunch it's like insane no
also it is bizarre how like literally
him and diana met for a total of an hour
like no i know i didn't realize that
that they really didn't know each other
when they got married at all and really
was like an arranged marriage because
the family loved her so much because she
was like this gorgeous girl and like
funny and outgoing and love music like
pedigree
what's not to well that's what i was
also confused about like was did diana
come from like she was lady diana
spencer yeah did she come from
a nice family like a wealthy family or a
poor one because at first she's in this
castle
uh when her when charles comes to visit
sarah and she's like living in this
palace
then she's sharing a flat with three
friends and is a cleaning lady yes so
she she comes from the quote wright
family because she is a
her dad was a lord and um she is
of that world aristocracy i know she i
guess like she could have stayed and
lived in the castle but she wanted to be
in london and live with her friends
got it okay so i was just like confused
about like her background yeah
they did not make it clear no i guess
it's confusing that she was like her
sister's cleaning lady yeah
but she was also a lady she's like also
a lady it was and i didn't realize she
was a lady until they announced her
at um somewhere
oh when they announced the engagement
they were like lady diana spencer and
i'm like
lady no she's a cleaning
lady like i was just [ __ ] confused so
that wasn't made clear to me but i had a
feeling
because then she was living in a palace
like it made no sense yeah no i guess
that is confusing maybe someone who's
familiar with like
royal aristocratic over socratic life
but i actually think maybe
maybe part of being a risk crowd is like
you have these titles and names in these
family homes but then like when it comes
down like to the cash like right you
have to get a job
yeah well that was the other thing i
thought was really interesting when um
margaret thatcher referred to her son as
her favorite it made the queen wonder
like who's my favorite so she like
met up with all of her kids she's
individually yeah who she like never see
never sees and i literally forgot that
she had two other kids i always think
it's just ann and charles
no i was like are they not going to show
us andrew well i
really thought they did an amazing job
with andrew like him being obsessed with
that movie where the girl's like 17
years old and like having all these
sensual experiences
and then the only thing she says about
andrew when she's talking [ __ ] about her
kids to prince philip is like
if we if we don't fix him like if he
keeps going down this path and then like
dot dot dot i thought they did a
brilliant job with that too like
foreshadowing what we know is to come
with andrew
but also like he was her favorite son
andrew was andrew yeah that's what she
came to the conclusion of yeah and you
could also see how that was possible too
because like
they were the only one he liked the
salmon like they had a fun conversation
yeah everyone else was like you know
either complaining i mean they were all
lost in their own ways but
like they just had a better rapport and
i don't think up until that point he had
done anything
illegal yet no but she saw it but she
could see but also
i don't know if like when she went home
that night she said that to her husband
no but it's the show runners like
narrative setting it up because i doubt
they'll go
they don't have time to go into the
jeffrey epstein of it all but whenever
we hear prison andrew that's all you can
think about now so you had to
address it address it and i thought they
did a really brilliant job but who knows
if she actually
knew at the time that right was a
problem yeah no
i but it was just like creepy to um
see it it was chilling when you finally
got andrew and i was like who's on this
helicopter i really didn't know like
what was about to happen and then it's
like
fun loving andrew was i guess who he was
yeah and like the queen loved it yeah
who knew she had a son named edward
no not me and the brace face like he was
bothering me so much
uh the other thing that i wanted to say
was i was actually surprised we got like
none of the wedding like we just saw her
putting a veil on you know what i
actually appreciated that because it's
like the wedding was televised go watch
it
that's true that's very true you know
but we got the dress and the wedding
happened they didn't make like a whole
thing about it because the
whole world lived through the whole
thing yeah um
and just like the queen in general like
i just love her like
i feel like olivia coleman when they
switched to olivia coleman i was like
this is annoying like because i just
gotten used to everyone there's so many
characters and they all kind of look the
same so
it's hard to remember then they switch
and i was like annoyed but i feel like
i've really come to just absolutely love
olivia coleman like i feel like she
really
captures like that queenie vibe which is
like kind of snarky and like funny
but like do not about her but i do feel
like the cast like
charles to me looks 18 years old like
he's a bit uh what age did he marry
diane i feel like he was
he's like 30 now that's the other thing
i feel like they really did a good job
of
making me feel really sympathetic
towards her because i didn't realize hey
like how young she was
b how she was like already struggling
even before she got there with with an
eating disorder like
was just not in a great place and i feel
like
they're doing a good job of like making
me maybe change my opinion yeah and also
building up to whatever
is to come i i agree like when she was
living in the apartment and she like
didn't have like one person like to be
so alone
all of that time like you know the whole
world is like writing about you and it's
like so exciting but meanwhile you're
just like bored to tears watching tv
reading fan mail yeah um and the fact
that charles
is absent yeah and he's in love with
another woman so clearly like
charles is to blame for the whole
situation i don't think you could blame
diana i don't think you could blame the
crown
even they shouldn't have intervened with
camilla parker bowles because it ended
up ruining it
i just i really don't think you can
blame anyone but charles and you have to
think like someone who's so
short-sighted and like
and i know it sounds harsh but like even
the queen says it's like you just like
the duty comes before anything else like
you want to go [ __ ] camilla parker
bowles like the duty comes first duty
like for everyone else they have their
jobs to do but you know what if you if
you need to do a little bit of this and
a little bit of that to get by go ahead
but like
you're the [ __ ] king right so i
know it sounds harsh but it's like we
don't care about your feelings charles
like
there's so much more at stake here and
the fact that he wasn't able to do that
and continue to be so reckless and
irresponsible
it makes you think like what kind of
king is he going to be totally the scene
where he's showing
his mom the garden my own little
shangri-la
and then he starts like quoting poetry
and she was like where's lunch
she's everything of the sort because
she's so focused on the monarchy and
she's been
able to really separate her personal
life from like her work duty life
and even her and her husband it's like
maybe in the beginning like she wanted
to marry him and she was head over heels
for him and then it got really [ __ ]
hard
but she stayed the course she never
wandered so when she's giving this
advice to the others
she's she's she's speaking from
experience it can be done like you can
build something great off of not that
much to work with to begin with
just mutual respect right when he said
that to charles the night before his
wedding like
it's a seed and then it blooms and then
it's 40 years of marriage like
it's work sure but like it can be done
she knows from experience her mother has
done it so many people before them have
done it
and i understand that it's like you know
you just want to go with every women in
your heart but like when you are a royal
that is not an option yeah and so i feel
like
it was just so messy and it gets so bad
and it's literally all because of
charles
and he was also at the end of the day
like
not a warm person it's like all right
it's one thing to not like be obsessed
with your wife and like be [ __ ]
someone else but like to leave her alone
for six weeks at a time and not call
like that's your wife like you you got a
call yeah
you gotta do something let her have a
friend over like something for sure
he was just the worst and i feel like so
many of the things that ended up
happening could have been avoided if he
had just been like
a more mature if you just went about
things differently
yeah yeah i agree and listen to his
[ __ ] grandmother i know he thinks
that
his family is cold and he's the one who
appreciates oh he thinks he's gonna be
the one to be the greatest king because
he can
he can be there and feel and appreciate
poetry no but like
he said in last season like that that's
going to be his
great asset is the fact that he he
is so empathetic sympathetic feeling but
it's like
it's actually not the way to do it yeah
i just
like really really want william to be
the next king like i just think he's
he he has the same vibe as granny like
monarchy first he didn't [ __ ] around
like when it was time to get married
like he got married to the best possible
girl he could find
who i think he also just like really
luckily also was in love with
um and they had the kids right away like
i just think he did everything right he
put the monarchy first
and i just think that type of behavior
should be rewarded i agree and i've been
seeing a lot of headlines but i haven't
been reading any
articles about the crown or what the
cast has said but i've been seeing some
stuff where it's like
this season is going to make people turn
on charles
good and i wonder how that will affect
the abdication the just like the course
of history i wonder if this show will
affect the course of history
i don't think so i you never know i know
they really do
take what the public says and the public
says to heart because they are public
servants
and i think it will be interesting yeah
i also think it's really interesting how
there's this like fluid
there's this fluidity between all the
seasons where it's like
queen elizabeth is known for like being
the youngest queen and like ushering the
royal family from like this kind of
unaccessible like
image to like being more relatable even
though they're still royals like
she really like ushered them into the
21st century yes
and i feel like i appreciate how that's
still a constant how like
whether or not she means it she's still
now in the fifth fourth season talking
about how like
it's important to meet members of the
general public and even though they're
putting on their gloves like
she still fancies herself like a
relatable queen yeah literally love a
relatable queen
literally but also it's so interesting
cause it's like she's responsible for
that change but the change came from
doing nothing like
allow like time and history
to do its thing and we will be this
constant thing like it's not like [ __ ]
to wake up every day and say what are we
gonna do it's like no we wake up every
day no matter how hard it is we do
nothing yeah and also it kind of um
what kind of i actually really liked
what she said is like she's now been the
queen for what like 50 years and
she's in the show in the show it's like
probably around 30 okay 25. so she's
seen like tons of different prime
ministers
wars um different eras of
crises and and it's when you're living
through those crises you feel like
like i feel like right now in america
this is the end like we are going
through a crisis like our country's so
divided and
and it's like it feels like this is the
end of the world and it's like it's
never gonna it's never been as bad as it
is now and it's like the worst
but hearing or being like it's just part
of a country like my country's bounds
back
you go through crises you go through
recessions but like you always bounce
back because they have to
it was very um comforting to hear her
say that yeah
and i believed it because she comes from
a perspective of like literally just
watching time pass
yeah i thought it was interesting it is
interesting she's she's a queen
no in every sense of the word she's the
queen yeah i love her
i love her too i'm excited to watch the
but i feel like i vote like
throughout all of watching every season
like i love her so much and this is the
first season where i'm
there have been some moments where i
just i just questioned you know i just
wish she was like a little bit
but i guess she has to be constant she
remains unchanged even if margaret
thatcher would have preferred
her to you know stay indoors for the
weekend like she's a queen she's
she's gonna do what she's always done
yeah no the ball morals weekend like
really rubbed me the wrong way like
especially like
like anne like just being so unfriendly
oh and margaret like even though
margaret
i don't know if this is actually how it
happened in history but she's the only
one who said we should not let diana and
charles get married like
as royals and as human beings like oh my
god it's so confusing
that princess margaret and margaret
thatcher have this oh sorry
yeah princess margaret was the only one
they were all in the office and they
were like yeah she was like we cannot go
through
this wedding and no one really seemed to
be that alarmed by the fact that they
weren't like so deeply in love
but she knew because she had been
through a very tumultuous marriage too
and i don't know if that's actually how
it happened but it's crazy that there
was one person like who
saw the potential danger yeah in the in
the wedding
yeah yeah it's just an excellent show
i'll probably finish it today
um i'm gonna try but with bachelorette
and all this
like maybe we'll do like two more
episodes i don't know how we can go from
watching like a cinematic
masterpiece like the crown to like an
actual piece of [ __ ] which is seventy
percent commercials
on abc like tell them it's like how are
these by interests
like i don't want to watch the
bachelorette yeah even though
i'm gay for tasha so like i will that's
true but like to go from
buckingham palace to balmoral to la
quinta
right to the bachelor mansion like it's
just nothing of the sort no it's really
not
um so we will keep you updated on our
journey to the crown season finale
hopefully tomorrow or the next day
um but yeah that's our show anything you
want to say before we
wrap it up no i believe that's all she
wrote you guys thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning shows of
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast-paced stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
so if you're watching us on youtube
please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have radio cast box all
the places we're now available on amazon
music
so wherever you find your podcast find
us the morning toast and leave a five
star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an incredible day stay
safe be nice to your friends have a
great day and we'll see you
tomorrow goodbye